good evening I'm Jennifer Giunta
Haussler from the 90-second streetwise
Charles Simon Center for adult life and
learning this lecture series is entitled
the Q linaria experience but as
tonight's guest will tell us the fast
food experience has become about a lot
more than what happens in the kitchen
tonight Eric Schlosser will tell us all
and then sign copies of his book in the
back of the room Fast Food Nation has
been on the New York Times bestseller
list for 17 weeks and will soon be
translated so that other countries can
learn more about why American children
often recognize the golden arches before
they recognize their name Eric Schlosser
has worked as a journalist for many
years writing for rolling stone and is
currently a correspondent for Atlantic
Monthly he received a national magazine
award for an article on marijuana
written for Atlantic if you didn't eat
at McDonald's tonight you may have
missed out on your last big mac please
welcome Eric Schlosser
well I'd like to thank you all for
coming here tonight there are a lot of
other things to do in New York City on a
Thursday night and I'm very flattered
that you've come to hear me I'd also
like to thank the 90 seconds 3y for
having me here the Y is one of America's
great cultural treasures and it really
is an honor to be speaking here tonight
tonight I'm going to talk about how i
came to write fast food nation thought
some of the things I learned during the
years that I was doing the research and
the reporting about some of the costs of
fast food that don't appear on the shiny
backlit menus and about the future of
this gigantic industry will McDonald's
always be with us or will it someday
disappear like american motors and the
Studebaker and Montgomery Ward I i'm not
sure it always will be with us first off
i should tell you a few things in the
interest of full disclosure I don't own
any stock in health food companies or
organic supermarkets and I'm not a
vegetarian I have a lot of respect for
people who decide to become vegetarian
for moral or ethical reasons but I'm I'm
not one of them I visited some of the
nation's biggest meatpacking plants and
I've seen some of the appalling things
that are happening inside them and it
didn't make me into a vegetarian it made
me angry but it didn't make me into a
vegetarian my favorite meal remains a
cheeseburger and fries and a chocolate
shake
though I haven't had one in a while I
didn't set out to write a muckraking
expose about the dark side of the
all-american meal I've eaten a
McDonald's since I was a kid I used to
take my children in McDonald's and buy
them happy meals but I don't anymore
this book started as an assignment for
Rolling Stone magazine the editors asked
me to look at America through its fast
food to go behind the counter and find
out how this gigantic system that
produces our fast food operates these
editors believed and I wholeheartedly
agree that you can tell a lot about a
country by what it eats and how it eats
when I took this assignment I really
didn't know anything about fast food
like most people I ate it but never
really thought about it when I started
this investigation I had no idea how big
and how powerful and how influential
this industry has become now of course I
knew that fast food isn't good for you
and I suspected that there was something
fundamentally different about it I think
most of us realize that almost
instinctively fast food tastes great
while you're eating it but then there's
always this moment about 20 minutes
after you're done where there's some
aftertaste and you wonder what did I
just eat
the real turning point in my research
was when someone gave me a pile of
confidential documents from mcdonalds
advertising campaign the basic thinking
behind this campaign seemed incredibly
cynical and manipulative to me there was
really nothing cheery and happy about
how they were planning to get parents
and their children into their
restaurants and then I visited Greeley
Colorado and I saw firsthand what's
happening in the nation's meatpacking
communities and that's when this story
became much darker for me the Rolling
Stone article ran in two parts and it
was very tough on this industry neon
winner the editor of the magazine never
pressured me to tone the article down or
cut things out or play it safe and we
never got sued by an industry that very
much likes to sue its critics but I felt
after the article had run that there was
a great deal I hadn't been able to
include and that I'd really only
scratched the surface of this industry
and its enormous influence not just on
America but on the rest of the world
what we eat and how our food is produced
has changed more in the last 30 years
than in the previous 30,000 without most
of us realizing it today's fast food may
look like food that we've always been
eating but it's really something quite
different it has been radically
transformed you have to look at
fast-food as though it's a manufactured
industrial commodity something much more
like a toaster oven than like something
that you had made from scratch and eat
in your own kitchen the fact is that we
are now such an urban
suburban eyes nation that most of us
really have no idea how our food is made
or where it comes from most of us have
no idea what's going on at the farms and
the ranches and the slaughterhouses in
the processing plants that now feed us
and I think it's very important for
people to know our great cities could
not exist without the agricultural
surplus of the countryside New York City
could not exist Los Angeles Chicago they
would not exist without the hard work
and the ingenuity of America's ranchers
and farmers that sounds corny but it's
the truth and it's something that's
that's easily forgotten in the year 2001
what happens on our farms and what
happens to our farmers directly affects
the rest of us from the beginning of
history civilization all civilization
has been made possible by agricultural
surpluses this is what allows some
people to move off the land and live in
cities this is what allows government
and science and the arts to flourish
we've lost sight of that basic fact of
how the city and the suburb is
fundamentally dependent on what's
happening in the countryside there is no
industry more important than agriculture
no other industry can survive without
agriculture a hundred years ago most
people knew this most people either
lived on a farm or had close relatives
who lived on a farm if you wanted a
chicken for dinner you had to go outside
and grab one chopped off its head pluck
it cook it in a pot
now some kids may find this hard to
believe but once upon a time there were
no chicken McNuggets and in those days
there was something healthy and proper
about being aware and being connected
directly connected to your food supply
today most of us grab shrink wrap
packages of meat off the shelf at a
supermarket or grab a plastic tray of
food off the counter at a fast-food
restaurant without a moment's thought
about how either one of those things got
there the main goal of my book is to
make people think about these things to
show where fast food comes from and how
it's made and how it's changed us the
fast-food industry has helped to
transform not just the American diet but
also our landscape our economy our
workforce our agriculture and our
popular culture fast food and its
consequences are now unavoidable whether
you eat it every day or have never had a
single bite of it now I tried hard to
write something that wouldn't be
simplistic something that wouldn't
demonize this industry I met a lot of
good people in the fast food industry
people I liked people who are well
intended I don't think that the
fast-food industry right now is being
run by a group of bad men who meet
secretly every week and plot how to make
us batter and poison us I don't believe
that I think the fast-food industry is
run by businessmen who are worried
mainly about their next quarterly profit
report about their company's latest
earnings per share about what Wall
Street will say about them and not much
else these businessmen are not really
worried about the long-term consequences
of
they're selling or the impact on society
they're not really worried about what
their products are doing to the health
of America's children they are focused
on narrow short term goals measured in
dollars and cents and that's why we have
to think hard about these consequences
about the consequences of buying and
selling and eating fast food because if
we don't think about them nobody will
now there are about 330 pages in my book
and only 10 of those pages give my
opinion about what should be done and
what changes need to be made to curb the
worst abuses of the meat packing in the
fast food industries the rest of the
book is just straight forward
investigative reporting there may be
some mistakes in the book and I'd very
much like to hear what they are the book
was fact-checked and went through a very
strict legal review the fast food
industry and the meatpacking industry
have attacked me and they've attacked
the book but thankfully so far they
haven't pointed out any serious errors
or factual errors in the book and I
haven't been sued yet for libel which
isn't in itself no small thing my aim
was never to tell people what to think
or how to feel about this subject I
didn't set out to lecture people about
fast food or to act like a scold you can
read the book and keep eating fast food
or read it and stop eating it but i do
believe quite strongly that you should
know what you're putting into your mouth
or into your children's mouths so that's
how and why I came to write the book and
now I'll give just a brief a brief
account of some of the things I learned
firstly let me give you a sense of how
big the fast food industry is today it's
huge
this year americans will spend about a
hundred and fourteen billion dollars on
fast food that's more money than they'll
spend on higher education personal
computers computer software or new cars
Americans now spend more money on fast
food than on movies books magazines
newspapers videos and CDs combined a few
facts about McDonald's will give you a
sense of this industry's scale and its
power McDonald's isn't just the largest
fast food company it's really set the
standard for the rest of the industry
it's business practices are widely
imitated not just within the fast-food
industry but also by companies in very
different fields McDonald's is a
colossus it is America's largest
purchaser of beef pork and potatoes the
second largest purchaser of chicken the
mcdonald's corporation is the largest
owner of retail property in the world
the company earns most of its money not
from selling hamburgers but from
collecting rent McDonald's now spends
more money on advertising and promotion
than any other brand it has replaced
coca-cola as the world's most famous
brand McDonald's is one of the nation's
largest playground operators and one of
the largest distributors of toys a
survey of american school children found
that 96% could identify ronald mcdonald
the only fictional character with a
higher degree of recognition with Santa
Claus the impact of McDonald's on the
way we live today is hard to overstate
the golden arches are now more widely
recognized than the Christian cross fast
food has become ubiquitous it is
literally everywhere an unavoidable part
of modern life more than one out of
every four
Americans eat at a fast food restaurant
every day we tend to take fast food for
granted as though it's always been
around but it really hasn't the first
McDonald's restaurant opened in 1948 in
two decades the company built 3,000
restaurants so in 1968 there were 3,000
McDonald's and all of them were in the
United States today there are about
30,000 McDonald's and the company opens
2,000 new ones roughly every year the
enormous growth of the fast-food
industry started really around nineteen
seventy it accelerated in the 1980s and
it hit its peak in the mid-1990s and
there was nothing inevitable about this
the growth of the fast-food industry
didn't occur in a political and a social
vacuum the extraordinary growth in
fast-food occurred during a period when
the hourly wage of the average American
worker was declining during this period
women were entering the workforce in
large numbers not mainly because of
feminism but in order to help pay their
families bills during this period
sophisticated mass marketing techniques
were being aimed at children for the
first time and the fast-food industry
and McDonald's in particular has
pioneered marketing and selling things
to children also during the same period
the real value of the minimum wage
plummeted by forty percent and it's
hardly a coincidence that the fast food
industry's biggest period of growth
occurred when the minimum wage was
falling so far
in the book I look at how the chains
have really helped change how Americans
work now when the McDonald brothers
opened their brand new restaurant the
first McDonald's in San Bernardino more
than 50 years ago they came up with a
whole new way of preparing food they
brought the assembly line system from
factories into a commercial kitchen and
instead of relying on skilled
short-order cooks who you had to pay
decent wage to they broke up all the
different tasks in the kitchen so that
one worker did the same thing again and
again and again one person would flip
hamburgers all day one person would make
french fries all death etc etc and in
this system it didn't really matter who
got bored and who quit because you could
easily find someone to replace him or
her because there was so little skill
involved in the job a new worker was
easy and inexpensive to put into such a
job now in this system nobody is
irreplaceable what matters most isn't
any individual or any individual skills
it's the system and it's the details of
the operating system that govern
everything now when Richard and Mac
MacDonald came up with this they weren't
trying to change the world they didn't
see any of the bigger implications or
ramifications of what they were doing in
their little kitchen in San Bernardino
they were just trying to cut costs in
their kitchen but the repercussions of
using that system in one restaurant is
really different from the repercussions
when there are over 200,000 restaurants
operating that way and that's how many
fast-food restaurants there are in the
States today the restaurant industry is
now America's biggest private employer
so what the restaurant industry does
with its
Koors has enormous implications for
every other industry well the restaurant
industry now pays some of the lowest
wages in the United States on average
only migrant farm workers earn less
money in America than restaurant workers
and so the influence of the McDonald
brothers has gone beyond the fast-food
industry into other industries that have
looked at this system for employing
people and have copied it and you'll
find throughout the service economy now
companies are borrowing from mcdonalds
and borrowing from the fast-food
industry the workforce that mcdonald's
cultivated part-time low paid unskilled
unlikely to stay on the job for very
long unlikely to ever join a union
unable to demand any real benefits is
the workforce that is increasingly
spreading through the US economy now in
the book I look at how the fast-food
chains have helped to transform the
American landscape literally have
changed what American cities and suburbs
look like it was Ray Kroc who had the
idea to take what the McDonald brothers
were doing in this one restaurant in San
Bernardino and reproduce it exactly and
identically at location after location
after location and it was really the
fast-food industry and McDonald's that
pioneered this whole idea of taking
retail environments and replicating them
throughout the country as a way of
growing your business now Ray Kroc
founded the McDonald's Corporation and
he eventually got rid of the McDonald
brothers because they he found them
difficult to work with the key to the
success of McDonald's according to Ray
Kroc could be described in one word
conformity quote
we have found out that we cannot trust
some people who are non conformists
crock once said about some mcdonald's
restaurant operators we will make
conformists out of them in a hurry the
organization cannot trust the individual
the individual must trust the
organization now that sensibility is at
the heart not just of how the fast food
industry spreads but a franchising and
of all the other chain stores that have
adopted its methods so it was crock who
made sure fanatically that McDonald's
restaurants always look the same and
that the food in them always tasted
exactly the same now other industries as
i mentioned copy this the founders of
the gap for example were quite open
about how they wanted to sell clothing
the way that McDonald's and KFC sold
food as a result when you travel through
this country and it's it's it's hard to
remember how recent it is it's really
only in the last 20 25 years you now see
the same restaurants and the same stores
and the same retail strips wherever you
go the differences between north and
south and east and west are rapidly
disappearing driven by this conformity
rate Crocs belief in conformity has left
an indelible mark not only on this
country but more and more on the rest of
the world and when you go to suburban
areas in the United Kingdom or in
Germany or in France you will see
Walmart and KFC and McDonald's and very
similar strips beginning to pop up now
in the book I look at how the fast food
industry has transformed
the food that we eat and how its
produced till the early 1960s everything
at McDonald's was made from scratch the
ground beef was fresh the potatoes were
fresh they were peeled in the back of
the restaurant every day but as the
chain grew and because of crocks desire
to have everything tastes exactly the
same at every location the company began
to rely more and more on frozen foods
and on processed foods instead of buying
ground beef from almost 200 different
suppliers McDonald's started buying its
beef from less than half a dozen this
had a profound effect on America's
meatpacking industry so as the fast-food
industry got bigger so did its suppliers
encouraging concentration throughout
American agriculture now in a different
era when this was happening when one big
company was merging with another the
federal government would have stepped in
and prevented it even in the Eisenhower
era the government would have prevented
many of these huge mergers from taking
place but thanks in large part to the
fast food industry American food
processors now have more power over
American farmers and ranchers than at
any other time in our history farmers
are being driven off the land in record
numbers indeed the United States now has
more prison inmates than full time
farmers today's agricultural economy
looks like an hourglass at the top there
are about a million and a half farmers
and ranchers at the bottom there are
about 275 million consumers who eat with
the ranchers and the farmers produce and
in the middle in the very very narrow
place in the
all there are about a dozen big
agribusiness firms that are earning
money on every transaction between the
two and really controlling those
transactions now fast food is some of
the most heavily processed food on the
planet almost everything in a fast food
restaurant arrives they're frozen or
dehydrated or as syrup there is very
very little cooking that goes on in
these places and that's deliberate for
the most part what's happening in a fast
food kitchen is frozen food is being
reheated frozen food is cheaper to buy
and it's much cheaper to hire workers
who only have to reheat things and don't
actually have to prepare them or cook
them now the problem with the system
that relies on processed food is that
when you process food when you freeze it
and dehydrate it you destroy most of its
flavor and one of the most mind-blowing
things for me as I was doing this
research was coming upon a flavor
industry that has arisen to manufacture
the taste not just that most of the fast
food that we eat but most of the
processed food that you'll buy at
supermarkets today this flavor industry
is is really a branch of the specialty
chemical industry and the heart of the
industry is Right nearby it's off the
New Jersey Turnpike in New Jersey most
of the flavor for most of the fast food
that we eat is coming from this
industrial corridor off the New Jersey
Turnpike now one of the chapters in my
books set out to discover why McDonald's
french fries taste so good and they
really do I mean they have a very
distinctive flavor that's different from
just about all the other fries that the
chain cell and the reason is this one
ingredient at the back
the very end of the list of ingredients
you'll see the sprays natural flavor and
it is a natural flavor I had to really
try and figure out where it comes from
and it turns out it comes from animal
products and from beef there's all kinds
of strange things that are being added
to our fast food that most people don't
realize Chicken McNuggets derive much of
their flavor from beef and from beef
extracts and there are all kinds of
really unusual chemicals that are going
into these flavor additives and I'm just
going to read you the beginning of a
list for example of a strawberry flavor
and what's in it a typical artificial
strawberry flavor like the kind that
you'll find in a Burger King strawberry
milkshake contains the following
ingredients amyl acetate amyl butyrate
amyl valerate anath all Anna still
formate benzyl acetate benzyl
isobutyrate butyric acid cinema isobutyl
and about 35 to 40 other chemicals that
have that name now by law the FDA
doesn't require these companies to list
the ingredients in a flavor additive but
if they had to the ingredients in these
flavor additives often out number
usually outnumber the ingredients in the
food itself now there's not anything
necessarily dangerous about these
chemicals but there's really something
strange about them about this whole
system about these flavor factories off
the Turnpike and for me this is
important not because I wanted to make
people scare to their food or scared of
these chemicals but really to show them
that this fast food is a very different
creature literally it's an industrial
product a manufactured product and for
me this is a very important symbol of
how our whole food supply has been
transformed in a lot
30 years now the fast food chains have
changed not only what Americans eat but
also what Americans look like it's
hardly a coincidence that as fast food
consumption has risen in the United
States so has people's weight the rate
of obesity among American adults has
more than doubled since the early 1960s
now our obesity epidemic has many
complex causes but there's little doubt
that fast food is one of them human
beings have an instinctive craving for
fat it comes from thousands and
thousands of years of scarcity of food
scarcity when it was really a struggle
to survive and we developed very
efficient mechanisms for putting on fat
and keeping it for the lean periods
we're not very good at losing the fat
once it's put on us fast food is some of
the fattiest high salt hi sugar food
that's sold in the United States and
this isn't accidental the amount of fat
in fast food is very carefully designed
and very very carefully calibrated to
make you want to eat more of it so this
industry is really addressing a basic
human craving and making an enormous
amount of money off of it the portion
sizes have also increased dramatically
in the last five to ten years because
the concentration in agriculture has
pushed down the price of the food so
much that these companies can now offer
you a much bigger serving and still make
a huge profit on it when you get a large
order of french fries there's just a few
pennies worth of potatoes in it so they
can give you a larger serving and and
make a lot more by charge you an extra
twenty to thirty cents they're only
giving you one or two more cents worth
of potatoes and that's true for the
sodas also which are really where they
make
most of their profit these super-sized
sodas that they're selling are basically
pure profit the only cost that they have
is the cost of the cup and the syrup
which is basically sugar and cost a few
pennies so it's been extremely
profitable for these companies to
increase their portion size but it's had
an enormous effect on American eating
habits and especially on the eating
habits of the poorest Americans who eat
the most fast food now if an adult wants
to buy a double cheeseburger with bacon
and a supersize fries and a supersize
coke it's a free country I think that's
great people should go right ahead but
one of the real problems that we're
facing today is obesity among children
and the way the fast food chains are
marketing these same high fat foods to
children and to me that's a very very
different subject entirely the obesity
rate among American children has doubled
since the late 1970s and we have the
highest obesity rate among children in
the Western industrialized world there
are children now who are suffering from
early onset diabetes in large numbers
their children who are six to eight
years old who are having heart attacks
because of their obesity the fast food
chains from the very early days have
worked hard to market their goods to
kids Ray Kroc again really pioneered
this and it wasn't because he loved kids
it was because he realized and he's
quite open in his memoir about this that
if you can get a child to come to your
restaurant you'll also get 12 of their
parents grandparents and the industry's
own surveys now show that whenever a
child get sets foot in a fast-food
restaurant the average check size is
much higher just because that child is
bringing in other customers
so the fast food industry and McDonald's
in particular has really pioneered very
sophisticated marketing techniques aimed
at children and that's to get them in
their parents in the restaurant there
are tie ins with the leading toy
manufacturers tie-ins with the leading
Hollywood studios and is it's very hard
now to distinguish America's fast food
culture from the popular culture of its
children if you look at what's in happy
meals and in Burger King children meals
though it's extremely high fat food and
the trend in the industry right now is
to actually make the portions even
bigger mcDonald's has just introduced
something called a mighty kids meal
which has a bigger burger and and so
this is a major major issue facing the
industry and it's very different from
selling this kind of food to adults now
a very big part of the book and one of
the parts that I think is is one of the
most important looks at the meatpacking
industry in America and how the
fast-food chains have really helped to
recreate this meat packing industry to
serve their needs in 1970 really at the
dawn of the fast food industry the top
for meat packers controlled about twenty
percent of the market for beef today the
top for meatpacking companies control
about eighty-five percent of the beef
that's being sold in the United States
there's never been this much
concentrated power in the meatpacking
industry going back even a hundred years
ago to the days of Upton Sinclair these
companies these meatpacking companies
are very powerful and they are very
tough and they have recruited a
workforce that in many ways is very
similar to that of the fast food
industry and I'm going to get into that
a little bit later but the
centralized meatpacking system that we
have largely to largely to serve the
interests of the fast-food industry has
also become a very effective mechanism
for taking dangerous pathogens and all
kinds of bugs that cause food poisoning
and spreading them throughout the United
States 25 years ago there were hundreds
of slaughterhouses in the United States
and today there are 13 that produce most
of the beef that Americans consume there
has been a huge rise in the last few
decades in a foodborne illness according
to the Center for Disease Control and
Prevention not all of that is due to
fast food but this centralized
industrialized system is a perfect way
to spread disease every day in the
United States about 200,000 people get a
bad case of food poisoning 900 are
hospitalized and 14 died and we're
finding that there are all kinds of new
pathogens that are entering this food
system like e.coli o157 h7 and Listeria
that we didn't even know existed until
about 20 years ago studies have found
that bouts of food poisoning not only
involved the acute phase of illness when
you're really feeling terrible but can
have lasting lifelong physical effects
now the outbreak of mad cow in the
United Kingdom is one more example of a
pathogen that no one had ever heard of
and no one had ever anticipated entering
the food supply and spreading throughout
the system before anyone realized it and
that's what our meatpacking system has
really made possible the meatpacking
companies and the fast-food companies in
the last 20 years have formed very very
close
ances with the right wing of the
Republican Party and have an enormous
amount of power in Congress as a result
at the same time that the industry was
becoming very concentrated and the
potential for large-scale outbreaks was
increasing our federal public health
system and food safety his system was
largely being dismantled at the moment
there are about a dozen different
federal agencies that are responsible
for food safety and more than two
different two dozen congressional
subcommittees that oversee them there
are huge gaps in enforcement most people
would be surprised to learn that the
federal government right now has the
authority to demand the recall of
defective stuffed animals but cannot
order the recall of contaminated need
that could potentially sicken thousands
if not millions of people right now all
recalls of meat or voluntary and while
the government is negotiating with a
meatpacking company over how much meat
does need to be recalled that meat
remains on the market and people
continue eating it now the question that
I've gotten most from people after
writing this book has been so what's in
my burger and the answer is if it's a
fast-food burger there are probably
pieces of dozens if not hundreds of
different cattle in that burger because
of the huge hamburger grinders that now
grind thousands and thousands of animals
together and there may be some feces in
it most of the outbreaks of food
poisoning related to meet are caused by
fecal contamination of the meat at these
slaughterhouses if you cook it well it
probably won't harm you and I go in I
explore
l'ainte in the book all the different
foodborne illnesses that are now being
spread through this industrialized
system but it was not my intention to
make people afraid of their food there
are a lot of things to worry about and
you shouldn't necessarily be afraid of
your hamburger the odds are it won't
make you sick but the odds are somebody
is going to get sick from that every
year about a hundred thousand Americans
come down with as bad ecola that's very
serious ecola infection so to
statistically it won't be one of you but
it's going to be someone and it's really
important to be informed about what's
happening and also as I discussed in the
book how unnecessary so much of this is
and with house with with stricter
regulation of the meatpacking industry
and stricter food safety laws nowhere
near as many people would be getting
sick what stays with me the most from
all my reporting for this book were my
visits to meatpacking communities and
again there's been an enormous change in
the last 20 years in what's happened in
meatpacking plants and into meatpacking
workers 100 years ago Upton Sinclair
wrote about the extremely dangerous
conditions in meatpacking but things got
better over the course of decades things
got much better in meatpacking plants in
the United States and by the early 1970s
neat packing was one of the highest-paid
industrial jobs in the United States
with one of the lowest turnover rates it
was a good job they were waiting lists
for jobs and American meatpacking plants
and as and then as the meatpacking
industry became concentrated and as
these four companies really three
companies wielded enormous power over
the industry they began to break labor
unions one after another and they began
to change the nature of meatpacking jobs
and they began to
to a whole new type of worker really
Mexican and guatemalan workers many of
them illegal immigrants so if you go
into a meatpacking plant today you will
find some of the poorest often
illiterate workers in the United States
working in a job that is unpleasant and
dangerous beyond my powers of
description according to the bureau of
labor statistics today meatpacking is
the most dangerous job in the United
States in 1999 more than one-quarter of
America's meatpacking workers suffered
an on-the-job injury or illness and that
means something more serious than just
going to get first aid the meatpacking
industry not only has the highest injury
rate it has the highest rate of serious
injuries as measured in lost work days
now if you accept the official figures
that means about 40,000 meatpacking
workers are injured every year but
there's very good reason to believe
those numbers are low and that the
actual numbers are much much higher
because of how vulnerable this workforce
is how rarely the injuries are being
reported and and the falsification of
injury reports so to give you a sense of
what's going on in these plants i'm
going to read off a list of some
accident reports from osha some meat
packing accident reports
okay great and these will give you a
sense of what's going on employee
severely burned after fuel from his saws
ignited employee hospitalized for neck
laceration from flying blade employees
finger amputated and chillin machine
employees fingers amputated in meat
blender employees arm amputated when
caught in meat tenderizer employee
killed when arm caught in unguarded meat
grinder employee killed when head
crushed by conveyor employee killed by
stun gun employee crushed and killed in
Hyde fleshing machine employee caught
and killed in gut cooker machine now
most of the injuries that are happening
aren't this extreme most of them are
lacerations people stabbing themselves
or stabbing someone nearby but the
injury rate is astronomical and one of
the things that I realized is that there
are many other countries that eat need
any beef and produce beef in
slaughterhouses and don't have anywhere
near the working conditions that we have
and don't have anywhere nearer the
injury rate that we have now one of the
big criticisms of my book after it came
out was that it was overly critical of
the Republican Party and one-sided in
its criticism of the Republican Party
well the fact of the matter is that for
the last 20 years the Republican Party
has worked very closely with a fast-food
industry and with a meatpacking industry
to avoid tough worker safety loss and
food safety laws and has really worked
to avoid the sort of regulations that
would keep real competition in our
agricultural markets I'll give you an
example
in the new Republican Congress
representative Charles Norwood has
jurisdiction over OSHA which is the
federal agency that looks after the
safety of workers now Norwood right now
is in charge in Congress of OSHA well in
the past congressman Norwood has
introduced legislation to abolish OSHA
one of the most serious problems in
meatpacking today are cumulative trauma
injuries which happened when you do the
same task over and over again
meatpacking industry has the highest
rate of cumulative trauma of any
industry it's about 35 times higher than
that of any other then of the average
and industry well representative what
congressman Norwood has publicly said
that workers tend to get cumulative
trauma injuries not from their jobs but
from playing too much tennis and from
skiing so it's hard not to be critical
of the Republican Party I'm not a
Democrat I'm a registered independent
and ideally all of these issues
involving food would be dealt with in a
non-partisan spirit sincerely it doesn't
matter whether you're a Republican or a
Democrat you have to eat and so do your
children although Democrats in recent
years have worked for food safety and
and for worker safety legislation and
have taken on the meatpacking industry
it was a Republican president a hundred
years ago almost who really was
America's greatest champion of food
safety it was a Republican Theodore
Roosevelt had the nerve to battle the
meatpacking industry and not just the
meatpacking industry but to really take
on the concentration
of economic power in this country and
unfortunately almost a century later
there really is a need to battle these
same forces once again so i hope the
republican party will soon reclaim this
great Republican tradition the 20th
century was largely characterized by a
battle against totalitarian power state
power fascism communism and I think that
this century this new century is going
to be dominated by a battle against
excessive corporate power worldwide it's
not just in the fast food industry or
the meatpacking industry it's remarkable
how similar our economic landscape is
becoming to that of 1901 and when I was
in these meatpacking communities in
Colorado and Nebraska and in Texas it
didn't feel in many ways like 2001 it
felt like a hundred years ago so the
question is will McDonald's always be
with us I'm not so sure seems hard to
believe there's so many of them they're
everywhere you can't escape them and yet
I think they're built on a very fragile
base there's a quote i have in the book
from a leading fast food executive about
the industry's fundamental dynamic which
is grow or die and the industry isn't
really growing in the united states
anymore as a matter of fact the year
2000 is the first year that the fast
food industry didn't get any new
customers in the united states and as a
result they focused all of their
energies on expanding overseas and
opening in every country that they
possibly can but their sales overseas
now are starting to slow and it may be
and i hope i'm not being overly
optimistic so the fast food industry
right now is like the british empire
right before the First World War it
looked huge it straddled the globe but
at heart at its core there were some
fundamental contradictions that would
lead to its undoing now the British
Empire still exists it's just very small
Gibraltar and the Falkland Islands and
in the same way the fast food industry i
think is either going to have to change
to adapt to changing conditions in the
new century or it's going to get smaller
much smaller I mean what the book tries
to look at is all the costs of our cheap
food that don't appear on the menu and I
think those costs are enormous the cost
of obesity are twice as high as the
total revenues of the fast food industry
so as people become more aware of what
they're eating and what their
consequences I think there is enormous
potential for change now I've spent a
lot of time holding the fast food
industry responsible for a lot of these
business practices but it's really not
that simple I think people have to take
responsibility for their own purchases
and for their own behavior nobody is
forced to buy fast food and this
industry exists really at the pleasure
of consumers so you know the future is
really in every individual's pounds I
mean you can keep on eating it or you
can stop buying it and it's really one
of the last remaining instances of you
can really have it your way
thank you
thanks thanks okay the first question is
is it from an ethical point of view or
how the food is process that convinced
you not to let your children eat at
McDonald's it's it's mainly from an
ethical point of view I don't want to
give money or support a company whose
businesses practices right now I
strongly oppose the power of McDonald's
is enormous and they could change the
conditions and the working conditions in
the meatpacking industry like that if if
they told their suppliers to change
their suppliers in the meatpacking
industry will completely change
production practices to sued McDonald's
in other ways so it's not that I'm
worried about my children being sickened
by the food it's not wanting to involve
them in this system and give money to a
company that I'm angry at if you had to
pick out one fast food chain to
patronize which would it be that's an
easy one there's a great chain it's
called in and out burger it's mainly in
Southern California Northern California
Nevada and the way that in and out
burger operates really shows that the
rest of the industry has no excuse for
its business practices in and out burger
uses entirely fresh food they pay their
workers the highest wages in the
industry they're their restaurant
managers on average stay working for in
and out for at least the average ten
years about twelve years whereas in the
fast food industry the typical manager
quits or is fired every year and the
typical in and out restaurant manager
earns about eighty thousand dollars a
year so it would definitely be in and
out /
and the food tastes great and I'm not
being paid by them for this plug I have
not been able to eat a hamburger since
reading your book and I love hamburgers
is there no place in New York City where
it's safe to eat one other than my own
kitchen well unfortunately my favorite
food as I said earlier is a cheeseburger
and I've been in these plants now and
and I'm 19 ground beef at the moment and
it's it's not necessarily because I'm
scared that it's going to make me sick
it's that I'm very angry at some of the
practices that are creating our ground
beef there are many different issues one
of them is e coli but one of them is
also some of the spinal cord material
that's being included in a lot of ground
beef legally included in ground beef and
I think people and especially children
shouldn't be fed spinal cord material
and bone marrow with our ground beef um
so is there anywhere that's safe the
odds are if you go out and get a burger
right now you can eat it and and nothing
will happen to you but if you really
really want to know what you're eating
the best way to eat a burger is by a
really good cut of meat bring it home
put it in the Cuisinart and cook it up
but at the moment i'm not eating ground
beef have you had any feedback from the
meatpacking industry since the
publication of your book yes they they
didn't like the book they really didn't
and and they had been very personally
critical of me but I've said this a
number of times and I don't want to be
tempting fate but they love to sue their
critics as Oprah Winfrey learned and
thus far of I've avoided that so the
criticism so far has been light compared
to what other people have received has
there been a backlash from mcdonalds if
so how have you handled it
mcDonald's has also criticized me and
the book and I've handled it by ignoring
it what kinds of foods meat products at
fast food restaurants are safest to eat
probably those chicken nuggets with that
little extra beef flavoring in them I
mean I'm you know it's a question of is
it safe to eat in the moment or is it
good for you to eat in the long term and
most of this food at fast food
restaurants is safe to eat in the moment
they've done a pretty good job at fast
food restaurants of getting the e.coli
out of the ground beef before it arrives
at the restaurant the dirtiest ground
beef is now being sent to supermarkets
and until recently was being sold to
American schools but but still you know
it's it's it's more of a long-term worry
than if you're starving and you go into
a fast-food restaurant you'll probably
be just fine what kinds of foods are did
that one what are you going to write
about next I'm going to write about
another cheery American topic which is
prisons in many upscale towns McDonald's
have been made to look different no
arches have they expended much effort
and money to fight towns over this you
know McDonald's has learned over the
years when there will be a great deal of
protest about one of the restaurants and
when there probably won't be and where
it may be a problem and where it might
not and so they have made a real effort
in certain situations to make their
mcdonalds blend in to urban centers and
certainly when there's a when there's a
risk of a protest they've worked even
harder when you're talking about a new
McDonald's and on a suburban strip or on
the fringes of new suburban sprawl they
will pretty much put up whatever
whatever they care to put up but they
have spent time
and taken great effort in recent years
to make their restaurants blend in
better why isn't the low cost of labor
counterbalanced by the high cost of
transporting the processed ingredients
one of the things I look at in the book
is how this industry in these industries
that are so openly committed to the free
market and free market principles have
actually been heavily subsidized by the
federal government in all kinds of ways
but one of those ways is the interstate
highway system and the interstate
highway system has made it very
inexpensive to transport agricultural
commodities in bulk over long distance I
mean we're talking about pennies pennies
per per mile and so and so
transportation costs are not a problem
with these big huge food factories
this is a comment about msg and and
monosodium glutamate obesity comes from
excess sugar not from fat if natural fat
the problem the fat the problem is the
fat they are using is hydrogenated
vegetable oils and I can't I can't read
I can't read all of this I'm sorry your
msg you don't have too late and you can
put natural flavor there I don't think
you can put natural flavor but there are
different phrases like ought alized
yeast protein there are different ways
to hide the msg that's in it did you
have any chance to learn about sugar
processing in your research and how they
depend on the meat industry no I didn't
it's not something I know very much
about you started by talking about the
importance of agriculture to the US
economy perhaps you know the book the
end of agriculture in the American
portfolio saying that agriculture is
over could you comment on this range of
perspectives together with the ongoing
loss of farmland all over the US I don't
think that agriculture is over and I
think that we've pursued a very
short-sighted policy in this country
that has really benefitted large
agribusiness companies at the expense of
farmers I think that Western Europe is
increasingly moving away from this
system the mad cows scare there and now
foot-and-mouth has really brought up
there and brought to mind and way in
Europe in the way it hasn't happened
are the dangers of large-scale
industrialized corporate agriculture so
you have Germany right now the
government in Germany is officially
committed to the deindustrialization of
Agriculture and is working very hard to
support organic agriculture but also
regional farmer small scale based
agriculture and I think that if you add
all the costs up together without having
to return to horse-drawn plows that's
really the direction that this country
needs to to head in as well which is
much smaller scale and much region more
regionally based agriculture that's it
thank you very much
I don't mix up